la bise de l'entraîneur fleuryssois sa
nouvelle marraine eminen d'ong et
l'emblématique joueuses de bourges et de
l'équipe de france de basket est suivi
de près cette rencontre au sommet grosse
intensité beau spectacle pour ce premier
match à domicile des défenses solides d
égalité qui se succèdent et quand
fleurissement de le prendre là chandon
metz rétorque grâce notamment à
l'international pour le beaudoin de
retour au plus haut niveau
à la pause les panthères ne compte qu'un
petit but d'avancé 15 14
la passion aux sur les 20 pour les deux
équipes tout au long du match et je
pense que c'est le gant à notre banquier
a fait la différence
ouais les ondes très peu parlent très
peu de rotation beaucoup de jeunes donc
voilà non lassus les épuiser tout au
long du match et voilà faire l'écart un
moment donné voilà et si l'écart n'a pu
être tenu en première période il a été
en deuxième les messines se sont heurtés
à julie foggea une revenante dans les
bus fleuryssois 8 arrêts à son actif et
un grand bonheur d'être là nouveau ça
fait un peu bizarre ça prend un peu les
chocottes mais ça fait super super
plaisir en tout cas de revoir la salle
de revoir les gens de
de sentir qu'on a la confiance aussi de
l'entraîneur des joueuses des joueuses
fleuryssoises en confiance passe à des
messines fatigué qui marque le pas et se
laisse distancer en fin de match 2 3 5
but d'avancé score final 27 22 les
plaisir sur le terrain et dans les
gradins
la première à domicile et réussi dès
mercredi les filles retrouveront leur
salle albert auger a fleuri pour un
match avancé de la 10e journée face à
nice